oh yeah you mentioned the critical
rendering path
it sounds pretty important it is the
critical rendering path is the sequence
of steps that the browser goes through
to convert the HTML CSS and JavaScript
into actual pixels on the screen and if
we can optimize that then we can make
our pages render fast which makes for
happier users cool so what's involved in
it so this diagram captures all of the
essentials first we grab the HTML and we
start building the document object model
we then have to fetch the CSS and build
the CSS object model we combine those
two to create the render tree then we
have to figure out where everything goes
on the page which is the layout step and
then finally we can paint pixels on the
actual screen wait a second though you
only talked about HTML and CSS
what about JavaScript ah right yeah so
that's a big important part of the
performance puzzle but before we get
there
let's talk about how we construct a
document object model the CSS object
model and then we'll talk about how
JavaScript affects the actual rendering
pipeline okay it sounds great